je serai votre sentiment sur les
mouvements concernant la manifestation
contre la retraite quand il ya autant de
travail qui a autant de chômeurs autant
de gens qui sont dans la logique comme
on dit aujourd'hui du burn out
qu'est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas à
repenser le travail c'est vraiment une
question philosophique pour moi je
défends le gilet jaune qui sont pour moi
les prolétaires je défends également ces
gens là qui pour le coup ce sont les
prolétaires mais qui sont organisés pour
parce que c'est toujours les mêmes qui
payent les pots plus modestes c'est
pourquoi ce sont toujours les mêmes qui
échappent soit à l'impôt soit aux
ponctions d'autres choses qui font que
s'il y avait vraiment un désir de
d'équité les français seraient
probablement plus à même de devenir
qu'il consente à ce traitement est ce
que vous avez compris quelle était la
revendication au moment des gilets
jaunes tout au départ ce sont juste des
gens qui disent si vous augmentez le
prix du carburant ne va pas pouvoir des
gens disaient mais moi je suis chez mes
parents parce que je ne peux pas me
payer un loyer alors que je travaille
donc dès le départ c'était une
revendication de dignité mais vous avez
dit on n'a pas écouté ces gens là
comment vouliez vous les écoutez puisque
personne ne prenait la parole et
personne n'était légitime pour
l'apprendre bien un qui est légitime
pour prendre la parole sur ce sujet là
ça s'appelle un président de la
république parce qu'il est investi de la
souveraineté nationale